for me personally really worked well is
to try to always to commit to more
things always try to get more things
done than you believe your realistically
were able to do if you aim for 200% at
least you get 150% up so deliberately
overload yourself with goals with
activities be okay to maybe fail with
some of these things so accept that job
sign up for the sports training group
take on this extra voluntary leadership
commitment in your community commit to
work on your own personal little
business project in the evening on the
weekend and yes if you do all that maybe
not everything will work the way you
hope to but I would be very surprised if
if you do all this you will not get done
much more